so couples because I want to talk about
first and foremost I want to talk about
hustle and no better example of hustles
and what just happened
right we had a situation it didn't
totally work out we improvised and
change the game and we're still able to
deliver to the community this is
something I do all the time with wine
library as a retail company when a lady
open ordered a case of behringer White
Zinfandel in December two years ago in
Westchester and FedEx [ __ ] it up and
she called the store complaining that we
were going to ruin her Christmas but she
didn't have her behringer White
Zinfandel during a hailstorm when while
everybody was in chaos trying to figure
out what to do I just grabbed the case
and drove to her house that's caring
about your community this tonight and
say is that instead of saying ah [ __ ]
nobody paid for tickets tonight it's not
like anybody really lost anything
Maxwell and I were upset we wanted to
come grill we didn't want people have
slept over here today and just for
meetup that's not which course cuz then
to you so we went [ __ ] outside and
now we're going to cross a Kino for you
[Applause]
let me tell you what I want one of the
things that's going through my mind
a lot of people are talking about the
economy how it blows how it sucks how
people are scared people are spending
cash all that [ __ ] fundamentally to
me what's going to happen over the next
24 months it's going to be the biggest
opportunity in our space created I'm
going to tell you why social media
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
if mature its Priscilla baby but it's
more mature than people realize it's
definitely a baby but it's mature like a
baby with a mustache right well you have
to understand is this major a company a
lot of companies are not going to spend
money in social media right now they're
scared they're cutting and the first
thing they're going to cut is things
they don't understand and so they're
going to cut some social media
opportunities which is going to hurt
some of your businesses because your
business is built on advertising I
understand
however what you need to understand is
the fact of these major corporations
that they're not jumping into this space
headfirst is the single biggest
opportunity for you whether you're a
content provider whether you're looking
to monetize whether you're a middleman
trying to broker deals the longer the
people that already have established
relationships in the market stay away
from this zone from this kind of product
the more opportunity you have in gaining
brand equity had the Wine Spectator or
Robert Parker or The Wall Street Journal
jumped in to online video when I did
there's a very good chance that I
wouldn't have not have the ability to
gain all the momentum I did with all the
wine people in the space but because
they took to the sideline that allowed
me to grow bigger stronger and more
powerful it's kind of like yeah
how many people here in this crowd no
way Yelp is raise your hand
yep in a 36 month period has
substantially set and hurt the zakat
grants how many people you're knowing
forgotten for has the God now is playing
catch-up a 25 year old business 5060
million dollar business playing catch-up
we have to understand is that the
internet fundamentally has changed the
barrier of entry to compete with
companies the cost now to build a
business is your time not your
pocketbook because the gatekeepers the
newspaper the radio the producers
because they're not in control anymore
because a clown like me can put a camera
in his office in New Jersey start
drinking wine and build brand equity and
nobody can stop me nobody that's a major
major shift in what's going on
advertisers that are not coming to your
space yet and are not getting it will
come because advertisers are very simple
brands are very simple they go where
eyeballs go right and the eyeballs my
friends are shifting as a matter of fact
I was in a taxicab just now and I'm
calling the phone number I want to buy
ad revenue I want to buy Wine Library TV
episodes in the taxi cab because that
the captive audience you've got to start
thinking differently people are not
watching television the way they use
them and on top of that the way content
is going to be distributed through
television has already changed if you
don't see what's going on with Apple TV
and what's going to happen with this
TiVo Netflix deal and what's going on
with biosis Time Warner Comcast in 24
months you're going to go to channel 999
on Comcast and search any content you
want on the internet and watching your
television and that's when should change
it that's when content will change and
you'll be able to monetize the problem
is is everybody that's standing you
right now and all the people I speak to
all the time and talk to on a everyday
basis have the same fundamental [ __ ]
flaw
not patient everybody here wants you to
happen now certain resin now so what you
need to do is take advantage and hustle
and build equity and build the
opportunity how many people here own
their name calm raise your hands
garyvaynerchuk.com raise your hand if
you own that for your name calm right
here I'll do it if you don't that is a
massive mistake okay go and find it
you're kind of smooth you're fun if
you're Jim Smith you're [ __ ] Gary
Vaynerchuk finally paid off
to me on [ __ ] Punk
I'm pumped because so much good shits
about to happen and everybody in our
space is crying that Main Street doesn't
get up
look you're spending all your time
trying to convince your friends to sign
up on Twitter and tell them why it's
important why it works that is the
biggest waste of [ __ ] time on earth
who gives a [ __ ] if they don't know
about Twitter or but company doesn't
that should be your [ __ ] secret
that's you're killing that I didn't go
around telling people all this run doing
this when I launched winelibrary.com in
1997 everyone thought America was making
fun of me because they thought the only
things I was selling online we're Opus
one and silver oak and always hard to
get items so I would Sally on 53rd ever
go to winelibrary.com
and pick up Santa Margarita when she
could pick it up next door but what I
realized then because I got in the
orders of people like convenient word of
mouth everything is different cultures
different people are different and so
that's the same thing everybody's going
to use Twitter whether Twitter is
Facebook or weather quitter is
Friendster and there's going to be
another product that comes out squeaks
that doesn't slightly better the general
concept of tweeting out and all that
shirt or texting on a big level is here
to say it's going nowhere just look at
the early adapter
how addicted to it and how often they
use it alright a couple other things
stop crying
there's so many people crying about
something making fun of somebody out
thinking thing stop worried about this
there is so much fundamental opportunity
if you're trying to make a business
model let me tell you what you need to
do whatever your niche is whatever your
subject matter is go out and take your
money and here's what I mean by that if
you've got a niche website you've got to
go to Google how many people here have
heard of Google you've got to go to
Google and you've got to type in the
name or the keyword in your space for me
that would be wine and then it would be
Cabernet chateau margaux things like
that any company that has a box on the
right side
spend money like that looking at find
the phone number and call them and
convince those people why your traffic
that is so focused and on point so that
subject matter is more valuable to them
than buying a [ __ ] stupid Yellow
Pages ad now it's there you just got to
take it there's so much opportunity the
time is now anybody who looks at a 17
how many people here have a brother
sister or somebody they're very close to
that is at the age of 14 to 18 raise
your hands watch those [ __ ] men are
the ones that are going to tell you
what's going to happen it is clear as
day that they are not going to be
watching television and I promise you
one thing
advertisers are not going to be spending
80 thousand dollars for a full-page ad
in sports [ __ ] Illustrated there's no
value in that and they're realizing that
and they're going to ship them they're
going to put their money elsewhere and
no matter what you do you need to
position yourself to be in that whether
you're a content provider or a middleman
who are doing the buying for a product
and start talking about a lot of you
work for companies when I consult for
companies I get a lot of the same [ __ ]
yeah but I have a muzzle I'm not allowed
to treat for my products there's too
much red tape whatever you do for your
own brand because if you don't say
anything then nobody knows you're
thinking it communicate your thoughts on
our space because when the people above
you get fired because they suck and they
didn't use this and they're going to
lose make sure the new people coming in
have some content that you saw it you
just couldn't make it happen it's a huge
thing for people to do on a corporate
level but I really didn't want to talk
that much I want to do a lot of QA I'll
stand here until there's no more
questions left please ask me any
questions if it's about social media
wine the New York Jets whatever
fire away t-shirts of Gazoo fire away
sighs all right my favorite $5 wine is a
wine called for Gatto from Portugal we
got to a Ponte by bone [ __ ] crushes
most $25 wine hey Carrie
what's your name sir ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha a lot of people are talking about
velocity get out
I think people have to understand what
advertisers want they want eyeballs so I
think anything that has eyeballs is
monetizable in my opinion if you have
2500 unique people a day coming to
whatever you're doing you should be
making Bank you should be able to live
off of that I really fundamentally
believe that yeah I know it sounds very
low 2500 uniques a day to me it's very
monetized well the problem is a lot of
people a lot of people don't position
themselves to monetize and that's and
that's what I get happy Wow
that's what I talk to people about if
you don't position yourself if you don't
redesign your website and most of all if
you don't go after people I mean for me
I did a case study for myself when I had
about 4,000 unique for my show and met
with a very famous wine glass company
and show them all the numbers and
there's a gun talk to them about what
they did in the Wine Spectator for
$70,000 a month and all this other
[ __ ] and at the end of meeting
and I didn't want to take it because I'm
you know I didn't take it because I've
got other monetizing things going on and
there's a lot of different discussions
with television going out of the side
but at that point he offered me twenty
seven hundred dollars in episode you
know I do five episodes a day there's
real money now that's because its niche
now again you might talk about
technology a lot of you do that's not a
snitch and that gets harder use that
twenty five hundred might be tougher so
it is individual but how many people
here consider themselves when they broad
they talk about social media technology
that kind of whole side raise your hands
high real high I want to see everybody
who did every person that says that has
their hand in the air if you're not
sleeping
if you're not leaving a Seesmic video
reply to every TechCrunch post every
single day you are a cloud it is a
madness neckline center network thank
you
sorry my friend but honestly you're that
fashionable sorry but I'm telling you
I'm telling you what I saw because
that's where it was launched first but I
saw these are places where you can build
equity the problem is people stay within
their own cocoon you need to go out and
work the community when Wine Library TV
had no viewers the way I got them was by
leaving content on other wine blogs even
ones that were ranked 11 million on
Alexa you know yes you go to them all
because you don't know where your
opportunity is going to be people look
at numbers too much everybody gets
caught up way too much and how many
people are on their RSS or how many
unique they have in a day you've got
you've got to build you've got to build
if you had here of all top management at
the brand snaps oh great puppy like fun
and valid Pepsi I promise 25 I got
something okay so what would you say
them what do you think is the most
important thing they need here hey
resource the question is if one if I
have a year and when I do talk to some
of them these big brands what would I
tell them about the space is that right
the social media space so here's their
problem here's the problem for Green
Mountain coffee and for Pepsi and for
Budweiser and Nabokov brand I talked to
yesterday they don't think there's
enough people and they're right the most
followed person on Twitter is Obama and
he has what a hundred thousand people
following him
okay so right now stickers about people
what I convinced them is two things one
they suck they want to spend money right
this base doesn't cost them money it
costs them time which lets have a money
value but not like the [ __ ] money
they spend by like poor those [ __ ]
that put that thing on that phone booth
right there you know how much that cost
a lot for that if you really cared about
your community so what I tell them is
this you need to immerse yourself in
this space because a lot of the people
in 2009 that gives the market are paying
attention to this market and it's a
trickle down and the cost is so minimal
that there's no value in not doing it
you know what I mean yeah so that's what
I tell them yeah
actually degree English language society
prefer further away
Salter heard that so I don't give a [ __ ]
about the English language okay so
that's first and foremost I think
they're absolutely there's no validity
to that I mean not marketing an
effective way with the English language
is the stupidest thing I've ever heard
because most people know that it's
visual it's emotional you know it
doesn't need to be spelled right to be
right welcome guys the problem is
everybody thinks about marketing from
like what can I do to catch a splash
it's a game of nutrition it's a long
process
you really have to give a [ __ ] about
your users the people that win really
care they were true community and when
that original families like for example
my vayniacs originally they're the ones
who build your brand equity whatever you
do you have to make sure your user is
the happiest son of a [ __ ] on earth
because then you crush then they do it
for you you will never have the time
everybody's always amazed by how much I
do but I'm only one person it's not
scalable I try to make unscalable things
I made a Facebook app today abstain
alcohol ask Gary you ask me a wine
question I [ __ ] answer it that works
for about two days until I got nine
hundred questions an hour I mean it's
not scalable but if you build passionate
users and you really give a [ __ ] about
them then that's the marketing the
marketing is see what you understand is
nothing's changed except word of mouth
word of mouth is what changed the
biggest [ __ ] Yenta on the Upper East
Side ten years ago that could have told
60 people about your product
now some clown in Ohio with a Twitter
account can sell 4,000 people in one
shot
weird a mouth has changed and if your
[ __ ] is on sweet and people passion
about your product that's what's going
to explode they can keep it going
forever steps Heil
yes a business model not relying on
content but is a business model give me
the example of democracy
so get satisfaction for government with
I okay it's the same game when you
launch that product it's an app it's a
web app so the early users you need to
listen to them so when they're like oh I
don't like the submit button because
it's pink you listen to that [ __ ] you
know or whatever it is and then the
other game is the outreach and you know
I live on Huffington Post and [ __ ] like
that just building up your street cred
not spamming and linking your [ __ ] just
getting your name out there oh when I
left all those comments on those blind
blogs Bullock said with Gary Vaynerchuk
that's it my name link back to my video
blogs but I never left a link in a
comment now a lot of people who are in
the SEO game think it's important I
don't I think it hurts you I think it
shows what your intentions are instead
of adding to the community you're trying
to suck out what I would do is be a few
or somebody else be a face of this
product live and breathe every politic
blog on the Internet and build up that
name equity and they see your quality
responses and thoughts and then they
click your name they find your site and
then when you get them into your house
you treat them like gasps
well what's your thinking you're going
to raise your hand servicer doesn't go
your way you know this banana is Gary
your tipping point what how can you
define it what was it my question was
what was my tipping point I have no idea
and I honestly when you like materialize
always working I'm so excited the day
before I started it I'm telling you the
truth for me if you're passionate about
what you do and you love it more than
life and you believe you know what
you're doing you want to ready the day I
felt I had something the first comment I
got am I on my bus the first thing I
mean it was always going to work in my
opinion there was never a doubt I
believe in is that hardcore I knew how
hard I was going to work for it and
that's it I don't believe in sipping
points at all I really don't I'm sure
there's always a moment was it when I
was on Conan O'Brien or when the Wall
Street Journal I'm sure there's
something you know being on diggnation
there's so many things that made it go
up with center networks linking up
Mashable talked about me whatever I'm
not sure but I know this that I never
looked for it and way too many people
look for their tipping point and that
goes back to not being added to your
staff I just wanted to say mark
slaughter that looks to me like you
spent a lot of what equity and time if
that leads up I mean that's the
commodity there's not the commodity but
this is the pain right if you don't work
you've no chance to many people I mean
it takes every minute you got depending
if this is what you want to do it starts
with what do you want to do is it's just
dollars and cents
[ __ ] that you're not going to win you're
not if you don't have your passion then
you've got no chance of victory and so
it's God have to come down to what do
you want
always
yes the American Community Development
question a lot of brands we talk about
say you know there's earned up to mass
social media $4 against it my response
to that to my clients is yeah but 1000%
particles there's literally no waste in
social media because if you put yourself
out there everybody who interact with
you is by definition a fan of the brand
or they wouldn't be there so there's no
wasted impressions where who is a TV or
radio or print of yellow pages or direct
mail or anything else how do you go
about that I feel that the difference
between a social media user today will
change but today as a consumer of a
product compared to the non social media
consumer is that a social media consumer
is an advocate they continue the
building process of the brand because
they are using the tool like Facebook
share like Twitter like that should
continue the story about your brand
there's also Nigerian noise so then if
you have to do social media more to
customer loyalty and retention tactic
more so than I combined with it yeah
both I mean it's like players right
everybody has players your baffle thing
as well players but trouble might suck
you might have customers but they may
not be doing anything for your brand
except for one way you know one way
transaction you know I thought I feel
that people that are social media
consumers are multiple traction and to
treat so much I mean listen if I love
your product and going sweet about and
do a video blog about it things are
going to happen and there's a lot of
people replicating like that on many
different levels
you know what let me let me finish with
this before it rains too hard so I keep
going successful I don't give a [ __ ]
about one brand that doesn't get get it
not for one [ __ ] second you know why
because they're going to [ __ ] lose
and be gone I'm not eating the business
to protect Pepsi from dying off and
letting some other brand coming I think
that because if you don't think it done
changes when platforms change just pay
attention to the five biggest selling
beers when radio was in existence and
what happened in the first five years of
television hitting some sort of critical
mass cuz Shaffer of Pabst Blue Ribbon I
promise you they would redo some [ __ ] so
the landscapes do change the next Red
Bull and vitamin water and blah blah
blah is going to come from this space
and they're going to spend a hell of a
lot less money than Red Bull and
vitaminwater did somebody's going to
crush it
kill the [ __ ] hundred million dollar
brand and do it for less than five
hundred thousand dollars and that's when
people going to be like oh now I get it
this place is going to become saturated
with people that don't want to finish
wanna get great results yes and then the
creamy rice at top and they'll get money
it's going on right now there's a [ __ ]
load of [ __ ] going on so there's only a
very small tear that makes money guess
what that's how it is out here too it's
always that but everybody thinks that
they have a blog or nurse social media
they're gonna get in they're gonna
question you've got to be good and you
got to work your ass off it's the same
principles that I've always existed if
you suck at sports radio talk and nobody
listened to your [ __ ] and you're not
going to be able to modify so make sure
what you do is something you're
passionate about and you're good at it
when you start professed am most Abraham
never only will to get people that they
suck yeah immediately very high on with
it I happen I have nothing to lose it's
not what I do I do a lot of consulting
but it's not my main source of income so
for me to walk in I [ __ ] the gap that
the founders meeting the other night and
said you'll get your feet penis that's
my opening line servile and it's proud
and he said those funds Bernie from ABC
who introduced me he's like I like this
kid because I don't give a [ __ ] if he's
out of business tomorrow I really don't
know what it's not what I can do if I
don't have time to help him you know
what's a winder Thurman fish what
guys thank you so much for coming out
Bob thank you for praising the elements
I really appreciate it thank you doctor
[Applause]
you